do you guys know why I envy this guy
because you'll never have to experience
crappy 3d conversion The Last Airbender
alright so as we've all seen M night
Shyamalan at Ding Dongs had some sort of
gradual decline from awesome and unique
to the happening and let's face it with
this summer's track record and Shyamalan
s recent movies my hopes were just not
up for the Airbender but surprisingly
this movie wasn't actually too terrible
too terrible then again you remember
Quantum of Solace where bond gives that
guy the bottle of Pennzoil and sends him
to walk in the desert and the guy ends
up drinking it he drank it because in
the hot dry summer movie seasons wish
there's nothing that comes out that
clenches your thirst absolutely anything
can look nice and drinkable I actually
think I might be getting there with the
Airbender because the acting wasn't
great or good the dialogue was cheesy
but what I really liked about the Last
Airbender was the lore certain people
can bend one element in this world but
this kid this avatar who's the last of
the airbenders can bend all four but he
never learned how to do that so he bends
wind right now it needs to go out and
learn how to bend the other three making
him one broken bastard and then freeing
and liberating little towns along the
way and starting a rebellion you know
stuff like that and if you don't know
what the elements are go back to school
or watch Captain Planet little hint
heart is not one of them and he's aided
by a waterbender and Jasper from
Twilight
like I said horrible acting and how do I
know that guy's name from that movie and
all the while he's being pursued by
Slumdog Millionaire whose character I
really liked in the movie I probably
liked him the most he's been exiled from
the Fire Nation by his father for being
weak so out of some sort of obligation a
duty honor or daddy issues he's going
after the Avatar but it's not really all
bad I mean sometimes he kind of wants to
be good but he's just like I I need to
be a dick and just get this kid want my
home back but just things in this movie
feel rushed mean it's 90 minutes long so
they don't have a lot of time and things
happen that should be monumental but
they're just fixed in like three minutes
kind of just takes away from the gravity
of the situation
this goes to show you that when putting
an epic on to the big screen needs to be
at least two hours minimum so the movie
is okay it's not great I didn't hate it
then again I watched Eclipse a couple
days ago so I'm surprised I'm not
hailing this as like an instant classic
the 2.8 d because that's what it is is
not really 3d it's [ __ ] it's
absolutely Clash to the Titans worthy
which goes to show you that when
converting a 2d movie to 3d you need
more than five months but it's rated PG
movie for kids if you have kids take
them to it they'll like it
I mean you know those kids movies that
are meant for kids and adults this isn't
one of them this is a kids movie
admittedly I haven't seen the animation
so if you've seen the animation you
might enjoy it a lot more because you
know the backstory that I don't know
so the mediocre middle of the lion
summer movie season continues with a
kids movie that has horrible acting and
cheesy dialogue yet a really interesting
story and lore I'll say this about the
movie it got me really interested to see
the animation so for nothing else I'm
gonna go see the animation I might just
be back here telling you to watch that
instead as it stands right now it's
probably the better idea but if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more than click right here to see
more